the summer months here are the time for
travel
but in Japan heavy rain and strong winds
brought on by typhoon land are
disrupting holiday plans across the
country
I have to be in school from the 17th so
there was no way I could stay in Manila
longer when our flight got canceled we
had to book new flights so we at least
in Japan now we're taking the overnight
bus back to Osaka it stranded
International Travelers too this is the
first summer since Japan downgraded kova
19 to the same category as seasonal flu
encouraging many to visit we had tickets
for a pike festival today so I'm really
hoping to go there because I was really
looking forward the thing is where we
have a Avenue Depot so
we hope we can get there today yeah
trains between Tokyo Station and Nagoya
a city in central Japan have been
greatly reduced many bullet trains have
also been suspended because of the storm
today
around 900 flights have already been
canceled this week
ninety thousand homes lost power in
Central and Western Japan the area's
hardest hit by the slow-moving storm 240
000 people were advised to evacuate
areas at risk of flooding and landslides
110 kilometers an hour wind speeds
caused injuries from flying debris
some cities in the Kansai and Tokai
regions have seen up to 300 millimeters
of rainfall in the past 24 hours that's
more than their average rainfall for the
whole of August
Japan's meteorological agency says
typhoon land is forecast to move away
from populated areas into the Sea of
Japan by early Wednesday
Hanukkah Montgomery Al Jazeera Tokyo
foreign